Do you find yourself for your team building internal apps
frequently for your company?
Are you familiar with the term forms over data?
They can be super empowering for your organization,
but they can also be pretty repetitive
and you might find yourself spending more time than you like
working on them rather than core products and services.
I've invited Jimmy Chan from DropBase
to tell us about their services,
whose tagline is build internal web apps with just Python.
It's a cool service and a fun conversation.
This is Talk Python to Me,
episode 460 recorded March 12th, 2024.
- Are you ready for your host, Daniels?
- You're listening to Michael Kennedy
on Talk Python to Me.
Live from Portland, Oregon,
and this segment was made with Python.
- Welcome to Talk Python to Me,
a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon,
where I'm @mkennedy and follow the podcast
using @talkpython, both on mastodon.org.
Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years
of past episodes at talkpython.fm.
We've started streaming most of our episodes
live on YouTube.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel
over at talkpython.fm/youtube
to get notified about upcoming shows
and be part of that episode.
This episode is sponsored by Mailtrap,
an email delivery platform that developers love.
Try for free at mailtrap.io.
And it's brought to you by us over at Talk Python Training.
Did you know that we have over 250 hours of Python courses?
Yeah, that's right.
Check them out at talkpython.fm/courses.
Hey, Jimmy.
- Hey, Michael, how are you doing?
- I'm doing well.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me.
It's fantastic to have you here.
- Thank you, I'm really excited.
- Yeah, I am too.
I saw DropBase, I saw what you all were building.
I'm like, that is pretty darn interesting.
I think people will want to check it out.
So we'll dive into this app and this platform
that you made for app building, basically.
We'll have a lot of fun.
Now, before we get into that, though,
just give us a quick bit of background on yourself.
How'd you get into programming?
How'd you find yourself writing a Python building platform?
- Awesome, yeah.
I went to school for engineering.
This was actually back in Canada.
I studied in Montreal at a little school
called McGill University.
- Nice.
- We started then.
I used to intern, by the way,
at this company called Research In Motion
that used to make BlackBerries way back in the time.
- Oh, yeah, awesome.
In the heyday?
- In the heyday, yeah.
I remember when they said we had 50%
of the US smartphone market share.
But the platform was actually built on Java, not Python.
Python was something afterwards.
Actually, my co-founder is the Python programmer,
and I picked up Python after we started working together.
- Cool.
You got any fun stories from your time at BlackBerry?
Did you enjoy it?
How long were you there?
- I was there as an intern only.
I spent about 16 to 20 months of internships.
- Yeah.
- At the time, I was, I think, in my third year of school.
And we were just working on these little Java apps
for the smartphones,
and just making sure everything was working.
The cool thing is when you work at a company
that's making devices,
devices have a very long development cycle.
So imagine, for example, you worked at Apple today.
The iPhone, what, 15, whichever one's coming next,
they've been working on it for at least a year,
probably longer.
So you get access to all these prototypes
that you get to use,
'cause you're building for it, you're testing it.
That was a really nice, nice, nice day.
But you actually couldn't tell anybody about it.
But it was really cool to know that you're on the last day.
- And you couldn't lose it in a bar
or anything like that, right?
- You remember those stories, right?
- Yes, exactly.
- It was all referenced a few times.
- Somebody got a hold of a lost phone,
and it was sold, and there was all sorts of drama.
It was a big deal.
That was around iPhone 4, 3, 4, 5, sort of timeframe.
- Yeah, I remember that very clearly.
- Yeah, so you didn't wanna be that.
You wanted to make sure you hung on to it.
- Oh yeah, no.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I think working for a company like that
would have been awesome, at least in the heyday.
It's cool to work for a tech company
that's got a lot of wind that it's back,
and a lot of people using it.
It's kinda neat.
- I was very happy.
We had a lot of other interns that they hired at the time.
They used that up lots to work in there over the summer.
- Yeah, a lot of excited people to do stuff.
Excellent, cool.
And so then you picked up Python,
I guess, when you started this project, is that right?
- Just a little bit before.
So when we started our startup, this was back in 2020.
My co-founder had been using Python.
He did a master's degree, computer science,
focused on machine learning, actually.
In that field, Python is really the main language you use.
- Yeah, it is.
- And so he was very familiar with it,
and so he set our stack, basically, to be a Python backend.
And then just through that process,
just looking at things and designing features,
we just all got involved with Python.
So it kinda just became the same.
And this is actually the reason why we're working
on a Python builder,
is we're kinda building a product for ourselves.
It's something where it fits our own needs,
that works with our mental models.
So that's pretty much it.
So today, I spend a lot of time building apps
with Dropbase, so internal tools,
and that's most of the app building I do now.
So building demos, testing the products,
making sure everything is working,
and then just finding other ways
to make the developer experience more convenient.
- It seems like something you could really take care
of a bunch of internal automation type of apps.
You don't have to create full-on web apps
to secretize this data or to get that dashboard or whatever.
You just fire up your own platform
and point at your data sources.
- That's right, yeah.
So the big difference with other frameworks
is that you're gonna use these frameworks
to build your customer-facing applications.
And customers, they have expectations
about what they need.
Interactions sometimes make a big difference for them.
UI components, the way models come up.
It's all part of the experience.
And so for that, you really need
a lot of extra components complexity.
For internal tools, it's not to say
that internal users don't have high expectations,
but the kinds of things that you do with those tools
tend to be very, very similar.
You search for data, you get context about that.
So for example, you search for a transaction or for a user,
you get some more context to make sure
that that's the user or the transaction
that you want to act on.
And then you just act on it, right?
Like you trigger an action on that item
or that resource or that person.
It helps you simplify the kind of things you need.
And so for that, having a framework,
a builder to make this happen is super convenient.
The subtitle catchphrase of DropBase is
build internal web apps with just Python, which is awesome.
And when I think of internal web apps,
or even traditionally, if you look back a ways,
there was VB6 and Windows Forms
and those types of things that were
kind of playing the same role.
So same basic idea.
There was a lot of people who referred to that
as forms over data.
It kind of the, not quite a negative term,
but kind of like we're sort of doing
the same basic architecture over and over,
but it's a different problem every time.
And so we kind of got to write code,
create these projects from scratch every time,
but they're the kind of, same kind of thing.
And so, I think that's partly why VB6
with its kind of visual drag and dropy experience
became real popular,
'cause you could drag a table on there,
drag a data source, bind it to that,
make a button click when somebody touches this thing.
And that didn't create something that would rival,
say, airbnb.com,
or where you have these really dynamic design sites,
but that's not what they need.
The company says, look, we need, this week,
I need our salespeople to be able to answer this question
and make this change.
That's what we need you to build this week.
And if it's from scratch every time,
that's a ton of rework.
- It's a lot of work.
It's funny you mentioned the forms over data.
It is true that a lot of the,
well, if you take it at a very high level,
all apps are forms over data.
- In some sense, yeah.
- All SaaS apps are forms over a database in some sense.
And then you start hearing also about the similar things
with you've heard about the GPT wrappers, right?
It's the same concept where it's like an oversimplification
of what's happening,
but at the same time, it is kind of core to what's happening.
And for internal tooling, at least,
is exactly what you need, forms over data, but very quickly,
so that developers don't have to spend a lot of time
basically doing the same things over and over again.
You wanna make their lives easier
to support their internal users.
So people in customer support, operations,
and I think sometimes even supporting
other engineers as well.
- Yeah, and it's not that people in companies
don't have expectations of nice apps and nice interactions.
It's just that it's more utilitarian.
Like so many of these big enterprises,
when you kind of think of them,
maybe the right way to think of them is
there's a massive Postgres
or Microsoft SQL Server at the center.
And like, it almost connects the business divisions,
like the sales team and the marketing team
and the product team and all that.
And if you can get into the database
and answer questions, expose data, expose relationships,
put a UI to some aspect of that,
you're really right at the heart of the company
in some sense, you know?
- Yeah, it's definitely about effectiveness.
One way we think about what these kinds of tools should do,
you have to enable developers to very quickly
build apps that have maximal value,
that lets you get the job done as effectively as possible,
but also that's easy to use for the end user.
So, you know, if it's like a business operator
or someone in the operations team,
they also need to be able to learn quickly how to use it
and trigger actions.
And so we call that sort of effectiveness of the apps,
some sort of like effectiveness score.
It just combines these components.
And that's really the, like,
if you can get to the essence of it
and create a framework or a tool builder
that maximizes for that,
I think you're in a really good place.
And this is something we're trying to do with DropBase.
The components are simple.
The kinds of apps that you can build look roughly the same,
but they look really nice.
And they're also quite simple to understand.
They're modeled after, but it's in a way
where you have data, a grid or table in the middle,
and then there's a sidebar
from where you can trigger actions.
And this ties back to this concept of
when you ask people in operations,
what they do, like sales, marketing, business operations,
essentially ties back to the previous comments,
which was you search for something,
you get context about it and you trigger action.
And so the way we translated that insight
about what people just end up doing over and over again,
we said, well, then you really just need
some sort of search bar,
you need a grid and you need a sidebar
with some buttons or some other drop downs
and other components.
And then you realize, okay,
this is kind of what stretches
I've been trying to do for a long time.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Except we like to trigger actions.
- Yeah, people do oddly connect Excel
to like external data sources
and all sorts of weird things as well.
Yeah, or write VBA that makes them change.
They probably should just not be doing that.
- Yeah, there's a lot of, it's actually a big use case.
One of our previous product,
we actually did exactly that.
We let you connect any database source
to your Google Sheets
and just kind of run that on a schedule.
So you'd imagine in a business setting,
you have sort of these like weekly, daily reports
that analysts end up working on, right?
And what you want is for the data to be fresh, up to date.
And so people just wanted a way to on at 7 a.m, 8 a.m
on Monday morning,
basically automatically pull data from the database,
load it up to your spreadsheet,
and then all your tables and calculations,
which is sort of updated
because they're referencing a tab, a sheet,
basically that has fresh data.
It is very interesting, the evolution of all these tools.
- It is really interesting.
Maybe one of the big differences is the interactivity here
versus what you might do in that story, right?
- That's read-only really.
And then here, what we're doing is letting you
trigger actions, perform actions,
basically outside the apps.
And you might call an API
or you might trigger an internal endpoints
or just some triggers matching in the UI.
- This portion of Talk Python to Me
is brought to you by Mailtrap,
an email delivery platform that developers love.
An email sending solution with industry best analytics,
SMTP and email API SDKs for major programming languages
and 24/7 human support.
Try for free at mailtrap.io.
I think we'll get to this more later,
but I wanna maybe touch on it
since there's a good question.
Also, it might be a question a lot of people have.
So what's the pricing model for this?
And basically more broadly,
what is the business model around here?
Luis says, "Already amazed by it.
"Would like to compare it."
First thought, there's nothing like this available
in open source, so very neat.
- The business model is we're gonna sell the product
on a per user per month basis.
So it's a B2B SaaS product.
Now, developers need to be able to play around with products
before they can decide whether that's something they want.
And so we have a sort of a free version of the products
that you can set up locally, like in your own machine,
or you can just put it up on an EC2
and you can just build apps for yourself.
Like if you wanna automate personal tasks,
you can totally use this for it.
And then the way that we, in a way, layer the pricing
is like if you need very complex permission systems,
so like you build an app and you want it accessible
by this person, by person A, but not person B,
then you'll need very granular permission systems.
And so that's an indicator that you're probably
like a corporate user, you're a business user.
And so we do the pricing based on that.
- The source is open, at least.
People can go and check it out, right?
Is that true?
- Let me clarify that.
So you can self-host it.
- Yes.
- You can look at the repo.
Behind the scenes, it's a Docker image that you set.
So the code for drawbase is not immediately,
you can't just browse it through the file system,
but the code is basically sitting in your machine
when you set this up locally.
Now, the difference here is if you look at the directory,
where you have the workspace.
So the workspace directory is where all your apps files
would be generated as you build the apps.
- Okay.
- That's really nice because you can essentially
version control this from day one.
You can build apps, you can check it in GitHub,
you can just keep your code, you can version it.
And so it's really, it's open source,
let's clarify that, but you can self-host it.
- It's on GitHub, but the licensing is really not like
just straight up GPL open source type of thing, right?
- That's correct, yes.
- Okay.
- And it's on GitHub because you do need to clone the repo
and then you need to send it out and install it.
- The free tier doesn't allow self-hosting,
but if you pay for one of the versions,
then it does have a self-hosting option.
So when you, just to wrap this up on the price,
when you say it's $10 per user per month,
is that per person that makes the project,
that builds the apps,
or is that per person that interacts with the web app?
- This is currently per member of your workspace.
So we're not yet differentiating between someone
who is building the app or using the app,
although that might be something
that we'll have to add later on.
- Sure, so if you had say four salespeople
and one "developer" in quotes maybe,
developer, that would be five users under this story.
- Correct, under the current pricing, yes.
- Okay, you know, even if it's not just pure open source,
take it and run with it,
I do like the self-hosting aspect of it,
because if you've got private data,
or maybe even more important than any of that,
is I wanna connect it to data sources that are,
I don't wanna give your cloud access
to my company database, for example.
- I can expand on that, actually.
So we built this specifically
with that comment in mind.
So when you're using internal tools,
it's very, well, let's say it's almost all the cases,
you are interacting with production,
at least one production database, right?
Like if you're supporting customers
and you're issuing them a refund,
you don't do that in tests
and then take it to staging and then deploy it, right?
You basically, you act on it on your production data.
And so we thought, okay,
people are probably going to be very hesitant
to basically say, let me load up all my creds,
all my API keys into some new player, a new cloud,
and then like hope for the best, right?
So when we designed Dropbase,
we call it the worker or the worker server,
the way you connect to data sources
is you basically go to your .env file
and you just add your database creds.
That env file sits in the same directory
that that workspace directory sits,
the one that we saw on GitHub,
and that's completely on your side
and that's in your VPC or in your local machine.
And the same server is the one that triggers the task
to query your database.
So, and that's also sitting on your side in your machine.
And so the entire part of the product
that processes queries, touches your data,
your data sources, your credentials,
that's completely on the user side.
And the only part that we manage
is really just the permission system.
So that controlling the workspace
and controlling the app permissions,
that's the layer that we control.
And that's really like the part
where we can do the pricing on, to begin with.
Like that's the feature set thing that helps us say,
okay, this is gonna be paid customers
and these are gonna be developers
who are just gonna learn how to code in Python,
just wanna build little apps for their own personal use.
- All right, that makes sense.
You know, let's maybe talk through an example.
If you go to dropbase.io, there's a,
right at the top, there's a sort of tutorial
or a demo video of you using it.
Obviously, I don't wanna just play the video,
but maybe just walk us through the steps
of what this app is and what are the steps to build it.
And just for people who are listening
and haven't watched that video,
maybe I think it's 12 minutes long
and you're like, let's create a new project.
And here it is published at the end, right?
Which is really nice.
So yeah, talk us through it.
- I'm gonna try to recreate the exact same one
that you have on the screen, right?
So it looks like an app that has two tables
and you can somehow perform an action on the sidebar.
Basically, it just notifies,
either notifies a user
or it performs some sort of permissions.
- I think what this one does is it has workspaces
and then users are in a workspace
and you can make them admins or not admins
of that workspace.
Is that what, does that help?
- Gotcha, perfect, okay.
Okay, so I'll describe how you build this app.
So you go to our app studio
and it's gonna be a blank canvas.
In that canvas, you can add tables.
So the first thing you do is you add table one,
you add the first table,
and then you would add table two,
which is the second table.
And then you add a widget,
so on the sidebar,
you just click on add button
and then it just places a button on the screen for you.
So that will be sort of a shell of the application.
It'll be just the UI part.
At this point, it's just a few mouse clicks.
There's no Javascript code
or Python code that you're writing.
The next step is to add the sort of the logic
behind the scenes.
The first thing we need to do
is to populate the first table
with data about your workspaces.
And essentially what we do is you click on create new,
you create a new function.
And in that function,
it could be a SQL function or a Python function.
Because that's just a table,
you can just create a new SQL function.
So you do create a new function,
select everything from workspaces,
let's say that's the table.
And then you can see a little preview
of what that select statement will result in.
So you can verify that that's the data
that you wanna show.
Once you've done that,
you just save that file, that query,
and you do something we call binding.
So in the UI, you can select table one,
and it'll present you with the tables properties.
And one of the properties is which SQL file,
which SQL script it's bound to.
So you just click bind to the SQL file that you just wrote,
and then it just automatically populates it
with data for your workspace.
Now, the second table is a little bit more interesting
because the second table will update
depending on what row you've selected in the first table.
When you click on a workspace in the first table,
it should load all of the users
that are part of a particular workspace.
And so we do this,
we have a feature called dependent tables,
and that's exactly what it does.
So for the second table,
you would still write a SQL query,
and the query would just say,
select everything from users,
where the workspace ID is the selected row
works as ID from the first table.
And we use that sort of a Jinja,
I'm not sure, maybe the audience will be familiar with Jinja.
It's sort of like Jinja templating style
where you say select everything from users
where workspace ID is double curly brace.
And then we have something called state.
They basically gives you the state of the UI
at any point in time when you've clicked something.
And it's really, we made it into a class
so that you can say state.tables.table1.workspaceID.
And we resolve that into the value
that's the workspace ID from the first table.
And so that's, and then you do the same thing.
You save that SQL query,
you bind it to the second table,
and then we automatically infer
that whenever you need,
whenever you select a different row in the first table,
the second table will update the workspace ID value,
rerun the query, and then show you the data for it.
- That's cool.
I was wondering how that happened.
I thought you must have to wire some on change event,
clicks over here, then it triggers that,
but you just have that all automatic, right?
- The UI actually knows that which tables are related.
The UI sends a payload to the backend saying,
this table was clicked,
and this other table is related to it.
And so we kind of know that we need to process those again.
And so that's how we do this dependent table.
For the getting the value of the workspace ID
in the first table,
we basically, we resolve the sort of the variables
in the backend and then pass a value
so that we can update the query.
So let's say that you stop at that point, right?
And then you say, preview the app.
The app would look like two tables
where it's really just lets you see all the users
for each workspace that you have in your database.
And then a few more things to make that very useful
is you might want to search for a workspace
before you know who to support.
So let's say each workspace is associated
with one of your customers.
So let's say company A is your customer
and company A gives you a call, a support call and says,
hey, can you make John in our company an admin?
So the first thing you want to do is you want to find,
you search for company A and then find John.
So we have this nice feature
that basically automatically creates searches for you.
So let's say in the first table,
you can click on a button to convert it to a smart table.
And when you do that,
we basically generate filters for you.
So you can then just say,
I'd like to search by company name
and you can select a filter
and you can pin the filter into the table
and that automatically performs a search for you.
I say, it's pretty neat that way.
- It reminds me a little bit of Notion, Notion tables.
I don't know if you play with Notion any.
- Yes.
- You know, you have got those pin sorts
and those pin filters and different things
you can kind of put at the top of the,
I guess their databases are called in Notion.
A little like that.
- It's very similar to that in the sense that
you're not writing any code
to be able to search through tables,
but you can still modify what you let people search
by pinning certain filters.
The really interesting thing that we've done here
is that we let you do joins
and still provides you that feature.
So in Notion, for example,
you would just have one database
and you can filter and sort that database.
With DropBase, what we have is,
let's say you have a table called users
and a table called roles,
and then they're related by an ID
where let's say ID one is users,
ID two is developers, ID three is admins.
You might have to join those two tables first.
And so that same smart feature,
smart table feature,
you can just write that SQL statement,
that join statement,
and we can still generate sort of the right filters for you.
And we'll actually let you edit those tables as well.
What we do is we take your SQL statement
and then we infer all the SQL required
to search or edit any column within the SQL statement.
- That sounds awesome.
- That's a really neat feature,
especially for the people who are used to using
something like Django admin,
in the sense that it helps you very quickly
build an admin panel with very little developer work.
You can just write a SQL statement
and then we give you an admin panel.
So that's really neat.
But the final thing with the app here in the demo
is the little button on the right side.
That is a Python function.
So you create a new Python function
and you essentially say,
you essentially write a database update
to update the role from whatever it was,
let's say from developer to an admin.
It's just really a select statement,
update table, that's column something on this particular ID.
And so that's just a Python function.
And the final thing is just to connect that button
to run this Python function.
You click on the button,
we run the function
and then we perform a database update
to update the role to whichever role you want.
And that really is just the gist of the demo.
- So a couple of things about that Python function
that's pretty interesting.
When you create it, you can say,
I wanna create a function and it says,
do you want SQL or do you want Python?
Which is pretty interesting.
The Python function has access to the UI widgets.
I get in the actual video, not the screenshot of the video.
I think you've got a dropdown select box.
And so the Python function go,
well, what did the user select?
And then we'll make the change to the person
in the workspace along those lines.
So that's pretty cool, right?
That you interact with this UI
in kind of a object oriented way, I suppose.
- That's exactly how it works.
So behind the scenes, we have two classes.
One is called state and one is called a context.
So the state class just lets us access
all of the UI state at any point in time.
Anything you enter in an input component
or any row you select in the tables,
you can see the currently selected values of it.
And so whenever you click on a button
or you perform an action,
that state is passed to the backend,
just as a payload, just like a dictionary.
And the backend, we generate all the classes,
all the objects related to state and context.
So we just have to pass the values in
and then execute the function
with those values as the input.
And so that's how we're able to do
the state thing with Python.
If you've seen how you would do it in Python,
it is very much a dot notation, right?
So you would say to get the value of column one
in table one, you basically just say,
state dot tables, which gives you all the tables,
dot table one, dot column one.
And that basically resolves into the value
of the table, of the row in that table for that column.
- Yeah, that's cool.
I can imagine the implementation of that thing.
It's like dot dot get adder.
And if you ask for the thing, you look in the dictionary
and you traverse the thing.
But with that in mind,
what I thought was really nice about this
is you had pretty decent autocomplete
in your little embedded Python editor.
How'd you pull that off?
- I did that you noticed, yeah.
We spent a lot of time on it.
- I bet you did.
- Yeah. - How's that work?
- When we were designing this,
we were thinking, damn, VS Code is really nice.
You have all the plugins,
all the autocomplete and everything,
but we had two choices, right?
Either we build this whole UI builder into VS Code,
or we kind of take some of the things
that make VS Code great
and then bring it into the DropBase Studio.
We don't know sort of the final,
eventually where this will be,
but the current version of this is we thought,
you know what, I think we need to give users an editor,
like a built-in editor,
so they can just quickly,
they can have the best experience building the app
and the access to UI and context and state really quickly.
We just did it that way,
where we added in LSP, so like a language server.
So anytime you type code in your Python function,
it's basically over a WebSocket connection,
basically streaming the code changes
and saving them in your file system.
That's the only way we can do this,
this like object-oriented Python.notation access.
And so we need to have access to all the files.
And so we set this up so that
not only you can do autocomplete,
but also that we can actually do the state and context
approach to the web framework.
It was a bit complicated
because we hadn't been really exposed to LSPs before.
And so we had to learn how to use LSPs
and we had to sort of hijack
sort of the WebSocket connection in a way.
So like we intercept the code
and then we save it in your file system.
So we had to customize it a little bit to do this.
And it's really nice
because now you can do autocomplete for your files.
It's just a neat, it's so hard to develop now.
We're so used to these tools.
And now with things like Copilot,
like we're used to even more than just autocomplete, right?
It's like autocomplete the function,
not just the variable, right?
- I feel like autocomplete is just table stakes, you know,
especially in this kind of thing.
You know, if there's somebody who's just done Python forever
and they're just, they'd rather get it out of the way
and it's fine.
It's not my way of working, but it's fine for people
who want to do that.
But if you're working with somebody
who might not be a full-time developer,
but they want to use your framework,
your service to build some app,
it seems like this could really empower them.
But if you give them something with zero autocomplete,
zero highlighting,
they're going to be having a rough time, you know?
- Yeah, even for a more experienced developer,
I think it's still a hard time.
- Even if you can do it,
it's just less productive to go like, oh yeah.
- Way less productive.
- Yeah, way less productive.
I think AI gets added to apps a lot
just to kind of check a box.
But the result of it is not that great
to get on my email client that has AI integrated.
But it almost always seems like, well, that's not something
I'd, yeah, that's something I want to read.
Like, I don't really want to read that.
And I don't need to summarize it.
That's emails, you know,
just seems like a lot of energy goes into it
when it's not that big of a value.
But maybe something like Copilot could be here.
- And this is something we've talked about,
me and my co-founder.
So one of the things that we didn't get to cover
because we're not going to go through all the demos,
but the way that we render data in these tables
is we basically format it as a pandas data frame.
So what that means is that,
let's say that you query data from Stripe, right?
Like you get all your customers from Stripe.
Stripe is not going to return a data frame for you.
It's going to return like an object, right?
A dictionary.
And then you basically have to take that dictionary
and then basically convert it into a data frame.
And then we automatically know how to render
everything else from there.
So we've thought about this and like,
wouldn't it be cool if as soon as you get the response
from an endpoints, let's say as a JSON dictionary,
that we suggest that we can just take it
that next step for you,
which is just to like convert it into a data frame.
And then you wouldn't have to hustle with it.
We've done that before,
but in theory that sounds very, very helpful.
If you're proficient in pandas and using data frames,
it's actually not that hard.
It's a very quick thing for you.
But if you just know Python,
but not exposed to the whole data frame ecosystem,
then maybe it would be really nice if you just said,
okay, we just started to data frame for you
and then that's all you have to care about.
So we've thought about this.
We haven't added this yet.
- I think it's fine without,
but it's kind of one of those things like you're in there
and you've got these data sources
and maybe you're not super familiar with them.
Maybe you can pull them together somehow.
- One of the things that I find myself struggling with is,
let's say I want to build a demo.
Let's say I haven't been exposed to like the SendGrid API
or the HubSpot API.
Then I have to go to their documentation to figure out,
how do I, what's the package name so I can install it?
How do I authenticate in?
How do I call a few endpoints to do what I need to do?
And I think in that case where it's like,
it's not about your knowledge of Python.
It really is about your knowledge of this other thing
that you're using.
In those cases,
it seems that it could be extremely helpful
for someone to build apps very quickly
if they somehow had access to either a quick documentation
or it just suggested what you might want to do.
- Yeah, that's kind of what I was thinking as well.
If you're a regular listener of the podcast,
you surely heard about Talk Python's online courses,
but have you had a chance to try them out?
No matter the level you're looking for,
we have a course for you.
Our Python for Absolute Beginners
is like an introduction to Python,
plus that first year computer science course
that you never took.
Our data-driven web app courses
build a full pypi.org clone
along with you right on the screen.
And we even have a few courses to dip your toe in with.
See what we have to offer at training.talkpython.fm
or just click the link in your podcast player.
- So speaking of that sort of external resources,
you've got this Python function.
What can I put in there?
Can I use external packages?
Can I call out on the network to talk to some API endpoints?
Can I spin up threads?
What can I do?
How much Python can I do there?
- Pretty much all of the above.
So I'll elaborate what I mean by that.
So the standard way that you would connect
to some of these services, these third-party services,
is you'll make like an HTTP request,
like GET request, POST request.
So you can just like import requests,
basically pip install requests,
and then just do it over the standard Python,
basically Python package.
Now, it is way more convenient
when you use an SDK provided by one of these third parties.
So if you wanna use Stripe,
if you're able to just import Stripe,
it'll make your life a lot easier,
you know, very nicely Pythonic, everything set up.
So in DropBase, you can install anything
that you can install via PyPI.
We have a file called custom requirements.
And if you just list them out,
when you set up DropBase,
we'll basically install all those for you.
And then when you write a function,
you can just basically import Stripe directly in the function
without, you know, pip installing it again,
and then you just use it.
So that's really nice, basically anything.
I think you were doing a previous,
UV, you were talking--
- Yeah, yeah, I was talking to Charlie Marsh
about UV earlier today, yeah.
- We haven't looked into it yet,
but anything you can pip install from, you know, from PyPI,
you can install in DropBase,
which makes it really, really powerful.
- Yeah, nice.
- There's a database connections.
I mean, you could use SQL,
or you can import whatever else you want,
but we make those a bit more native
because we know that you're gonna connect to databases.
So we wanna make it a bit more a convenience.
So--
- And your tables need sort of direct access
to it as well, right?
Not just the output of some access to the database,
but you've got to figure out the columns
and all that kind of stuff, right?
- That's correct.
So for, we created a little library,
like a utility slash helper
that lets you perform database operations very quickly.
So if you've added your database credentials
to the .env file,
then you can quickly perform, you know,
like a select statement,
or you can make an update to that database via functions,
but without, you know, the standard thing where you do,
if you use SQLAlchemy, for example,
where you like start a session, start a connection,
you know, like all those steps,
we kind of abstract that for you,
but you can totally use SQLAlchemy in its full glory
if you, you know, if that's what you're used to.
- Nice.
Can I write Python files,
like separate Python scripts and stuff,
and then just import and call them from there?
Or does it have to be done through the UI?
- Totally. - Yeah?
- This is actually one of the biggest advantages
of DropBase is that if you have like a,
like a Python script lying around
and you want to sort of use it in DropBase,
you can add it to that file system
somewhere in the workspace directory,
and you can just import it in via your function.
So you just like, - Okay.
- From your file,
you can import a specific function in that file,
for example.
And so, so the implication of this
is that you can set up DropBase in a way
that it just lives in your existing Python code base.
So imagine you already, you know,
you've set up your company,
you've got product market fit, you know,
things are running, right?
And you have a Python backend,
and now you're starting to scale
and you need to build tools.
So your first option would be to do all custom,
obviously.
The second option is to use some sort of tools builder,
but every single action you take
is done over an HTTP request
with authentication, with everything.
So just like a standard internet communication.
But if you wanted to just interact
with an existing functions or internal endpoints,
then you'd have to either set up an RPC server,
or you might want to use some other way
to get in there, right?
With DropBase, you basically just set up DropBase
in the same directory as your app,
and you can then import selectively what functions you need.
It's sort of like a window into your code base
that it's like a plug into that code base
where you can now expand and build a lot of internal tools
that leverages everything that you've already built.
- Yeah. - That's the way, by the way.
- Yeah, when you've got,
oh yeah, there's the requirements like custom, right?
So you've got your Docker compose file.
I mean, could you set it up just so as you build,
it may be even better,
just set up a volume so that it can directly find,
I mean, I guess that's what you're kind of showing
right here, right?
Is that you can sort of map,
mount the volume just directly into say your Git repo
for your big project code,
and then you can just start importing that
and doing stuff with it, right?
- We still need to do some tweaks
because of relative cats,
but the idea is that you can do that
with a little bit of customization.
But yeah, our Workspace Server,
basically you mount files or directories,
and then we can look into those to execute.
- Yeah, manage those files with Git or something like that.
- A good example of this is,
are you familiar with Django and Django admin?
- Not super as I do every day, but I'm aware, sure.
- Django, it's a great web framework.
It's used by a lot of companies.
It's like, if you wanna build web apps,
Django, it comes with a lot of stuff, right?
And there's this thing called Django admin
that basically automatically generates admin panels for you
based on your Django models.
And so if you have a model for like a book, right?
In the book as authors,
it basically exposes that to the Django admin.
And then now you can edit a book
without really doing anything.
Like it all kind of comes for free.
Like it's pretty neat.
- I think that's like half the appeal of Django right there.
- It is, yeah.
I think a lot of people use it for that.
- Yeah, they're like, I don't wanna write that stuff.
I'm using Django.
Yeah, for real.
- And it's great.
Now, at some point when your company hits a certain milestone
or a certain number of customers,
you will need to customize those admin panels.
You might need to create admin panels
for things that maybe you don't have models for yet
or for things that combine data from your database
with data from like Stripe or some other source.
And so what we see when we talk to these people
is that they kind of struggle to like,
either do I like keep using this
or do I like completely rebuild everything?
For those users, when we talk to them about DropBase,
they get very excited because with DropBase,
you can install Django and it can sit in your file system.
And so essentially all the models
that you've already built in Django,
you can basically call them via DropBase
with DropBase function 'cause it's all Python, right?
And so it gives you this like, okay,
Django admins are great up to a certain point.
And then after that, what happens, right?
Like you might not wanna rebuild everything
just so you can have internal tooling.
And so I think that's quite of a nice spot for us to say,
look, DropBase can live in your code base,
uses everything you already have,
but it gives you some extra things
if you want to build internal tools very quickly.
So that's something we're obviously very, very excited about.
- That's really cool.
I like that aspect of it.
So when we talk about this code,
I guess there's two scenarios,
the cloud version or the self-hosted version,
but where and how does this Python run?
Is it, it must be full CPython?
Is it running in isolated Docker containers
or in your cloud, what happens?
Is it functions like AWS functions, Lambda?
- It just runs either on your local machine,
if you've set it up as a developer,
it's all running there.
Obviously, if you could turn off your machine,
you can use your apps.
And then if you set it up in a production instance,
let's say you deploy this on an EC2,
your Python functions are running on that EC2,
but it's running via Docker container inside.
- So it gets a little isolation,
a little bit of protection, that kind of stuff.
- And we're assuming that,
I mean, you're building these apps
to run on your own infrastructure,
is that you would, that you know what you're doing.
So this is as opposed to us having a full cloud version
where all customers run untrusted code
in the same sort of backend system,
which would be obviously very dangerous
'cause I'm sure there's ways a customer can somehow,
you know, go through the back
and then access other customers' untrusted code.
And that would be a nightmare.
And so if we have isolation,
first layer is, well, it's in your infrastructure,
you're gonna do, it's just your company's code,
but then further, you know,
we run Python in containers in that instance.
- That sounds more like a durability thing than anything.
I mean, it is also for isolation and protection,
but first and foremost,
just don't let bad Python code
take down the whole thing, you know?
- The way we recommend people using Dropbix
or setting up their dev sort of process with Dropbix
is that they would clone,
it's like basically fork the work Dropbix,
and then they will develop locally.
They will test changes.
And once they're happy with the new code,
you know, they'll push it back
and then they will have CI/CD into the production instance.
And then they can version control everything.
So that also gives you that extra layer of,
okay, let's make sure that whatever we're pushing is tested.
You can always add test databases
that you develop locally with
before you push to production,
where it's gonna have to act on your production data.
- Yeah, that's pretty interesting.
I like the version control aspect of it.
That gives it a much nicer touch
to connection to real software,
rather than just it's a text input area in an app
that who knows what happens.
- As developers, it sometimes feels a bit scary, right?
Like you're building something
and it's in this other framework, in this other cloud,
and it just feels like you can't kind of get,
like if the thing goes away,
like you can't even see your previous code.
That was another key concept that we wanted to have
is in this tool that it feels friendly for developers,
that it matches your mental models
and your sort of like your development process,
let's call it, like how you're used to making apps
or developing code,
that we keep that feeling
when you're building apps with TrapFace.
- I wanna maybe have a PR to understand
if we accept this change to it, right?
- That's right, yeah.
- Yeah, you don't normally hear that kind of stuff
around these kinds of tools.
- And if you do, I think it tends to be like,
yeah, okay, it's like a huge enterprise contract,
pay us $50,000 a year, and then you get version control,
which to me, it sounds scary.
I mean, it just,
it will make me a little bit less comfortable.
Now, obviously, if I'm a big company
and I just really need the tool,
sure, maybe I'll just pay for it and I get version control,
but getting version control,
it just feels so like,
like table stakes for developers, especially today,
that yeah, it just wouldn't make sense otherwise for us.
I mean, it's the way we're approaching this product.
- Yeah, well, the other aspect is,
what are you version controlling?
Do you end up with something like effectively
a Jupyter notebook, like big blob of something,
and then there's an older blob of something,
and then you diff it, you're like, what is this?
But since you end up with just these,
your workspace files that just live there, right?
It's a real optimized, like show me the changes,
show me what's happened here.
- Yeah, it all lives there,
including the component properties.
Like we don't store this in like a separate database
or anything like that.
So like, you know, like for some of their tools,
they will store all the components in their database.
And so what they do is, you know,
when you load up their tools, like their tools builder,
it'll fetch all the components from the provider's database,
combine it with maybe your custom code,
and then it'll do it.
And so even that feels like, okay,
but where's like config for my components?
- Yeah, where'd this button come from?
Why is it gone?
- That's tough, yeah.
And then like, imagine if you wanted to like share apps,
or, you know, it's just like version control
makes a bit less sense.
I mean, you're just version controlling,
just like the individual functions,
maybe like some custom part of the code that you write,
which is still useful,
but it still feels like you don't have the full picture
of what's happening.
- Yeah, you don't have a full record.
It could easily get out of sync.
- Yeah. - Quite interesting.
I guess one thing we touched on a little bit
before I press go here in the show,
you said that at one point you were considering
using Jupyter and this whole mechanism.
Yeah, what's the story around that?
- We love Jupyter, we love notebooks,
and we love the experience of them.
The sense that you can write some code
and you can quickly test and execute the code
without, basically without needing to write anything else.
So for prototyping, for getting quick feedback, it's great.
And we wanted to give our developers something like that,
because when you build these apps,
you're kind of iterating, right?
You're like, you're testing it.
A lot of the times you don't even know the documentation
for Vibe or HubSpot or,
and so like there's a lot of experimentation.
And so we wanted a quick way to do that.
So we considered maybe having something
like a Jupyter kernel within DropBase
that allowed people to do it.
There were some issues with it,
is in the sense that the kernel actually stores results
from like previous blocks.
And sometimes that gets in the way
of you triggering an action in a later block.
And so we were like, okay,
maybe that's a little bit more than we need.
Now we still kind of eventually want something like that.
We hacked it in a way, like, so the way that we do it is,
you can write a Python function.
You basically get one block.
You can write a Python function
and you can click on a play button
to basically run that function,
but it's not like a kernel.
So what we do is behind the scenes,
we have like a main function.
And when you trigger that function,
we take the state from the client.
So whatever you've selected or input it,
we take the underlying file for your Python function,
and then we call it from me.
And so we kind of simulate that experience
of like instantly testing code that you just wrote,
but there is no,
like there's no Jupyter kernel behind the scenes.
And then you can only do one block at a time.
And so we said, okay, for now,
as we're getting started with it,
it's good enough that you can write your functions.
You can run and test them immediately,
which is really nice.
You can do this with VS Code, by the way,
like you would have to open up the terminal
and then basically run your function.
And so we still wanted this feature where you can click
and just see your outputs
and basically debug and troubleshoot,
but it'd be really nice if we get out multiple blocks
and you can just build functions that way.
So maybe for the future.
- Interesting.
- Did you say that you were a core developer for Jupyter?
- No, no, I just spoke to them.
It sounds fun, but I was just,
I interviewed a whole bunch of them recently.
And what I thought was interesting is,
Jupyter is such an empowering thing for Python developers,
but many of the core developers are so focused
on writing JavaScript and TypeScript
to sort of make these interactions possible.
So the rest of us don't have to write JavaScript
and that kind of stuff.
- So I think we're getting about
to the end of our time here.
I'm sure that actually this is somewhat similar.
It's really a dynamic interactive web app.
And in that case, it probably has to have
some interesting front-end JavaScript stuff going on.
What's the JavaScript story?
- Yeah.
- What framework are you using and stuff like that?
- We use React to build our components.
Obviously we abstract that away
so that you as a Python developer,
you're just writing Python,
well, you're writing SQL as well,
but let's call that Python.
And then we deal with the components for you.
And so it's not the kind of framework
where you're writing Python
and we're generating HTMLX or something like that.
So obviously we understand React
and we know we can build some beautiful components,
customize them with it.
We weren't about to create a completely new framework
where we somehow just generate HTML from Python.
I think there's a few people working on that, actually.
We already know React,
so let's just build those components
or customize those components
and then just let people declare them
and then sort of access and modify them
via the context objects in your Python functions.
So our stack, we use FastAPI for our backend,
which is great.
- It's excellent, yeah.
- I'm not sure if you've had the creator here on.
- Yeah, I've had Sebastian on,
I think at least three times, Sebastian Ramirez.
- Yeah, he's great.
- Yeah, he is really great, yeah.
FastAPI is a fantastic app.
And so, yeah, we use them.
We use React on our client side
and we are a lot of our infrastructure is on AWS.
- Yeah, sounds really interesting.
Sounds like a fun app to work on.
- Yeah, you should play around with it.
I can help you build some apps
to manage your podcast library.
- All right, well, Jimmy,
I think we are pretty much out of time.
Final thought for people listening,
maybe they're excited to try this out.
What are you telling them?
- Yeah, just go to dropbase.io
and sign up for a free account.
It's free for developers.
You can set it up locally.
If you have any issues setting it up,
just reach out.
I'll personally help you get it up and running.
Yeah, you can look at the documentation for everything else.
- Yeah. - Let's try it.
Give us some feedback.
We'd love to hear from you.
- Awesome.
Congrats on building a cool project for people
and yeah, good luck with it.
- Thanks, Michael.
- This has been another episode of Talk Python to Me.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Be sure to check out what they're offering.
It really helps support the show.
Mailtrap, an email delivery platform that developers love.
Try for free at mailtrap.io.
Want to level up your Python?
We have one of the largest catalogs
of Python video courses over at Talk Python.
Our content ranges from true beginners
to deeply advanced topics like memory and async.
And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight.
Check it out for yourself at training.talkpython.fm.
Be sure to subscribe to the show,
open your favorite podcast app and search for Python.
We should be right at the top.
You can also find the iTunes feed at /iTunes,
the Google Play feed at /play
and the direct RSS feed at /rss on talkpython.fm.
We're live streaming most of our recordings these days.
If you want to be part of the show
and have your comments featured on the air,
be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
at talkpython.fm/youtube.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Thanks so much for listening.
I really appreciate it.
Now get out there and write some Python code.
(upbeat music)
For more information , Plz visit the website of HealthWY.com